let's go straight to the phones let's go
to
hannah in mercado minnesota hannah how
are we doing
uh good how are you so good so good all
right
walk me through what's going on how can
i help
so i'm a new stay-at-home mom i just
started staying home in march do the
pandemic and then just stay at home
um and we're just beginning our journey
with the baby steps like we're just
planning everything out and i'm kind of
feeling like
i'm failing my husband a little bit not
bringing in an
income and helping break down our debt
gotcha
all right so walk me through a few
things number one
how long have you all been married um
it'll be five years in january
five years and how long did y'all date
before that
uh about a year and a half before we got
married
okay all right so six and a half years
you've known this dude right
yeah he's a good guy yeah he's a really
good guy
do you hear how your voice changed it
was like i'm failing him i'm terrible
yeah he's a really good guy so good for
you okay so and how many kids do you
have
uh three three how old are they uh my
oldest is two and a half and then i have
five months old twins
oh my so you are in it in it in it right
yeah okay and when did you
you decided to stop working in march
what was your career what were you doing
before then
i worked in a daycare okay so you are
all about taking care of little ones huh
yeah so we knew i was gonna stay home
when i had the twins it just got pushed
a little ahead because i was high risk
pandemic and stuff and because you were
growing two humans at the same time
yeah and it's just we couldn't make it
work with daycare very cool
all right so for those listening that
don't know the baby steps
i work for dave ramsey the get out of
debt
guy the guy that is preaches hope and
financial security
not being in debt not being slave to the
lender
and one of his programs is the baby step
programs
and step one is to get a thousand dollar
emergency fund
so if you do have an emergency or more
likely when you have an emergency
you borrow money from yourself not from
some credit card company or some bank
that does not have your best interest in
mind
and they are trying to make a buck off
your misfortune the second step
is what he calls gazelle intensity
pay off all of your debt smallest to
largest so
hannah you find yourself with three kids
still a relatively new marriage
you've transitioned out of full-time
work
and you're staying at home and you're in
baby step two how much debt are you guys
trying to pay off
i think it's like 60 000. okay somewhere
around there what's your husband do for
a living
he works construction oh so he's
grinding it huh
yeah he's gone before we wake up till
sometimes the kids are in bed when he
comes home hmm
but he's making it happen and it is not
fun to work outside
in construction in minnesota is it
no it's cold wow what a stud all right
so what's your household income
um i think around 60 or 70.
okay so
here's all that's all the context i need
here's a couple of thoughts i want you
to keep
in your heart and mind over the next few
months and
few years okay
getting out of debt is a really
important goal
in fact it's a critical goal it's one
that transformed my family
it transformed the peace in my soul it
transformed my family tree
when my kids see credit card ads they
all boo it's hilarious
so it's a good thing right now
you have two goals i want to put ahead
of that
goal number one is your young marriage
you've got a husband that is absolutely
kicking butt he is working hard dark
till dark
cold cold cold minus temperatures right
and you have three young kids
three tiny kids and that would be tough
for any marriage in any situation
and then the second thing is i want you
to focus on the goal
of being present with those kids
and so we live in a culture where
identity is based on achievement and it
used to just be boys
were given that but women have absorbed
that too
you are only worth what you achieve you
are only worth what you make
financially what's in the checking
account and what we've got now is a
generation of men and women
who if they take a pay cut if they lose
their job
if they make a decision which i think is
an
honorable and noble decision to leave
the workforce and be present with
three young children right three kids
under three
yep then suddenly you look in the mirror
and think
i'm not worth much or what am i actually
contributing or i'm a drain
on this family and i need you to hear me
as
say it as as boldly as i can that's an
absolute lie
you are a gift to your husband you are a
gift to those little kids
they need you fully present with them
and you are doing something much more
valuable than earning a paycheck
and you are giving three young babies
their their mother's full focus what a
gift
and so transitioning out of this this
consumer mindset this
i'm only worth my paycheck mindset is
going to require you to grab
hold of a new identity and most of us
myself included have not done the hard
work to figure out
who we are i've been working on it for
about a decade i'm getting closer
my wife experienced this she went from
dr dalony she was a professor
in a rock star she was a teacher before
that
and then she chose to stay at home and
it was tough
as she made that transition to who am i
now right
and every woman's got to go on that
journey for themselves well i strongly
recommend that you surround yourself
with women who are ahead of you in this
journey who are stay-at-home moms
themselves
who have been there who know the ups and
downs
i also want you to surround yourself
with women who are going to be really
graceful with you
because you've got three kids under
three
in any circumstance in any part of the
world in any stage
a hurricane has hit your house it's a
joyful one
but it's also one with lots of diapers
lots of cha-cha lots of mommy mommy
mommy
lots of like your body is utilitarian
right now it's not even yours
and your husband is out grinding it and
grinding it
and it's hard to say hey i need some of
you too
because you know you don't want to be an
imposition on him you've got to
learn how to let your voice be heard in
your home
but most importantly you're gonna have
to craft in some cases from the floor up
a new identity and it might be the ceo
of the home it might be i run this place
he goes and earns a paycheck
but i'm making it happen it might be i
am a full-time mom it might be
i'm a mom in this season and then i'm
going to go back and i'm going to own my
own daycare center
or i don't want to do that but my kids
are going to go to the daycare center
where i work whatever that happens to be
but your identity is somebody in
addition to work
it's something that holds up work we
were made to work we were made to love
our identity is deep
our identity is deeper than a paycheck
deeper than a job
so hannah on 20 different fronts i
salute you
i salute you for making the hard
decision to stay at home i'm proud of
you for that
i salute you for being an absolute ninja
for taking care of three kids not taken
care of for raising
loving three kids under three i honor
you for
being a great wife and loving that
rugged outdoor construction husband
who's out there working dark to dark and
sub
freezing temperatures i salute you for
all of it
so i want you to get some people in your
corner and go craft an identity from the
floor up
and anytime it seeps into your mind i'm
just a drain on this family
remember me saying that's a lie
i don't know where that's coming from i
don't know if it's from your mom from
your dad from
whatever social media accounts you
follow wherever that comes from
it's a lie you're worth everything
to that husband you are worth everything
to those kids and you're worth
everything to everyone listening to this
show i'm so grateful you're in the
communities that my kids are going to be
growing up in hannah
and now it's time to go do the fun hard
gut-wrenching work
of finding out who you really are and
who you're going to continue to grow
and become it's awesome hannah it's
awesome